and the rebound ripped down by Tomlin up
ahead Noel
oh Johnson
Razzle Dazzle for the jam oh the standby
official and we're off and running here
sweet 16 is alive and right away the
Kansas State Wildcats go up top for a
highlight Michigan State covered in 8-0
Kansas state run
now Johnson going to work Rises up over
hogard
shakes his head can't guard him which
will be his second that's into Hauser
hack the son oh pass it significance
they didn't even pay attention
but the trust factor that he has from
his coaching said more importantly from
his teammates allows him to be the
general speaking of General Johnson
Johnson huge here in the second half
and they look at a Zone here from the
lose to start with
oh baby Johnson
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Big Shots tonight he's got 20. they
double him
Noel lobs it up
[Applause]
we have to slide over and help right now
do not leave John Luna on the island
with fiance Johnson takes the three over
him and buries it yeah but naquan needs
to give it up quicker to one of those
guards
oh
and there's a bucket by David cassan who
was starting now coming off the bench
provides some offense
here's Noel
Johnson
oh boy all right now it's Kansas's turn
here we go Johnson shoots over
here we go
coming off a big win over TCU on Tuesday
they knew they would get Texas Tech's
best keante Johnson
Champs it with a foul
Noel on the move and he pulls it back
out
there he goes
Johnson
thank you